this morning we continue our special
series kindness 101 with steve hartman
sharing stories that are built around
themes of kindness and character and the
people who have mastered those qualities
today's lesson is enthusiasm steve and
his kids introduce us to a former bus
driver whose enthusiasm created a
lasting bond with the students he drove
to and from school each day
good morning this is my daughter meryl
hi we couldn't be more enthusiastic for
our listen on
enthusiasm and for a definition let's go
over to your brother emma at the
dictionary desk damn it enthusiasm is
like a special kind of joy that fills
you with energy to do something
perfect
have you guys ever heard of ralph waldo
emerson
no
never no it doesn't ring a bell for me
oh like where's waldo
no no not where's waldo
this is a guy that wore i think he wore
a different shirt every day and he was
also a writer too
emerson once said nothing great is ever
achieved without enthusiasm and he's
right enthusiasm is crucial to success
and if you want definitive proof
look no further than our library of
living life lessons and this story about
a man with a busload of enthusiasm
you can see why someone might hate being
a school bus driver the early hours when
the weather sours the abundance of
responsibility combined with the absence
of eyes in the back of your head y'all
have a good day nevertheless curtis
jenkins loves delivering these little
ones to lake highlands elementary in
dallas texas yes emily gruninger is the
principal he goes way beyond the
outlying responsibilities and duties of
a bus driver i mean that bus is like a
family these are my children these are
my community i love them all to
establish community what's your job man
he starts by giving everyone
responsibility this is one of the police
officers it's an elaborate flow chart
she's the administrative assistant to
the president administrative assistant
yeah
everyone working together to build a
yellow bus utopia
and we're going to care about each other
and we're going to love everybody right
i put time effort love care
understanding understanding each and
every one of those kids omar to show his
love and understanding
curtis gives presents throughout the
year you say you like baseball each gift
personally selected with that child in
mind
he gave this girl a t-shirt her first
book with a picture from a book she made
i'm hoping this t-shirt inspired her to
keep on writing books
over the years he has bought these kids
bikes backpacks handed out cards on
birthdays and even turkeys at
thanksgiving he has spent thousands out
of his own pocket
and yet if you ask the kids what they
like most about curtis
the gifts
don't even come up
he really cares about us is really kind
and he helps anyone in need
ethan engel is a fifth grader means a
lot to you yeah
he says the bus ride is often the best
part of his day
my mom got divorced when i was only four
see you tomorrow he's the father that i
always wanted
in some ways i
just i wish my dad could have been like
that
we make the mistakes sometimes of
thinking certain jobs are more important
than others
but curtis proves with a little
enthusiasm
you can make any job important
a lot has happened since we first told
that story and joining us now to tell us
about it curtis jenkins hello how you
doing steve we're doing great do you
still drive a bus
i don't drive a bus at this time i was
promoted you were promoted yes teaching
other bus drivers so you began teaching
other bus drivers how to be like curtis
jenkins
yes some of them didn't have to do too
much
it was a great opportunity for me to
show the enthusiasm that i had
with the kids and give it to someone
else sounds like a good job it does
sound like a good job are you still
talking to the kids that were on your
bus route yeah i go to the school
frequently and i see those kids those
kids are very very very
dear to my heart uh ethan he's going to
the ninth grade now actually we stood up
for a little lunch date me and him and
his mom
in your opinion do you think that people
can make themselves feel enthusiastic
about something
you can't make this up because you know
what any job that you get you can find
some type of joy everybody can find
purpose in everything that they do
i'm just grateful that you've decided to
dedicate yourself to children so thank
you so much and thanks for being with us
oh thank you thank
you and thank you too
we'll be back here again
enthusiastically next week until then
stay kind
[Music]
got it meryl that's my favorite part
stay kind but how about the little boy
that said about curtis jenkins i wish my
father could have could be like that i
know yeah but i mean how about what
curtis has to say about a job i mean
people always say like it's not always
fun that's why they call it a job yeah
still muster some enthusiasm for it if
you connect it to something bigger and
he does yeah especially when it comes to
kids and when you care about your job
pouring that into them that's for sure